[Música]
bienvenidos a el debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález sólo dos meses
después de haber asumido el cargo como
presidente de perú pedro castillo ya
hace frente a una crisis ministerial que
comenzó con la dimisión de guido bellido
que era el presidente del consejo de
ministros lo que generó un remezón en
las altas instancias del gobierno y así
ocurrieron las cosas se lo mostramos
señor leal y fielmente el brazo una gran
inestabilidad política en perú el
presidente pedro castillo ha iniciado un
nuevo capítulo en su gobierno que ha
terminado con el nombramiento de siete
nuevos ministros y que comenzó con la
renuncia de guido bellido ex primer
ministro del país
informó al país que el día de hoy
hemos aceptado la renuncia del
presidente del consejo de ministros
guido bellido ugarte a quien le
agradezco por sus servicios prestados a
la nación la renuncia de bellido
simpatizante del grupo terrorista
sendero luminoso supone un
distanciamiento del mandatario con el
ala más radical del gobierno desde su
juramentación dos meses atrás bellido
tuvo disputas recurrentes en el congreso
y siempre nuestra nuestro cargo a
disposición está en la mesa del
presidente
y el presidente de la toma de decisión
de acuerdo a sus convicciones de acuerdo
a sus criterios
políticos que tiene
uno cuando asume esta responsabilidad no
puede preguntar de por qué
o como
simplemente uno tiene que cumplir
todo lo que está enmarcado
en la constitución ahora el presidente
ha remodelado su gobierno con una carta
más moderada con el nombramiento de
mirtha vásquez política ambientalista de
izquierdas como nueva primera ministra
junto a seis nuevos ministros con los
que ha pasado de dos a cinco mujeres en
el ejecutivo una estrategia con la que
castillo espera lograr más consenso para
sacar adelante sus iniciativas
pues ya lo veían unas horas más tarde el
presidente castillo nombró como sucesor
a de bellido a mirtha vásquez ex
presidenta del congreso y también
parlamentaria por el frente amplio
muchos especulan que este nuevo gabinete
servirá para mejorar la gobernabilidad
del país pero también es visto como un
punto de quiebre del presidente castillo
con su bancada algo que podría traerle
problemas en el mediano plazo esa la
gran pregunta podría generarle problemas
al presidente porque al presidente
castillo le ha costado tanto estabilizar
a su gobierno anclar las fichas clave
para que el gobierno marche y vaya
alcanzando entonces la altura para
lograr el vuelo de crucero
también revive los fantasmas de la
gobernabilidad en ese país suramericano
el impeachment las instituciones la
inestabilidad la falta de norte
institucional pero la crisis sin fin ese
es nuestro tema de debate hoy en france
24 y para profundizar en él saludamos a
cecilia valenzuela analista y directora
del diario perú21 también está con
nosotros josete yo analista político
abogado y miembro del instituto peruano
de derecho electoral ambos se encuentran
en la ciudad de lima la capital de perú
y aquí en el estudio de france 24
conmigo se encuentra josé cepeda él es
politólogo doctor en ciencias políticas
y también administración pública y
también es docente universitario ustedes
también nuestros televidentes pueden
participar en este debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales estamos en facebook
en instagram en twitter síganos como
france24
arroba sant y luego les recuerdo que la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios para que
ustedes también participen y sean parte
de esta mesa pues comienzo entonces con
cecilia en la ciudad de lima
preguntándole si fue una decisión
lo que ocurrió ayer en perú esta
decisión de retirar a todo el gabinete
hacer un remezón en los ministros era
algo que se venía especulando o tomó por
sorpresa a la opinión pública
hola santiago en realidad se venía
esperando
yo creo que los días se contaban en el
sentido de cuando termina el presidente
castillo de sacar del gabinete de la
jefatura del gabinete allí ha venido
pero no sólo ha ido venido sino también
a un
ministro el de trabajo de pedido para mí
que se demostró había sido militante de
sendero luminoso y había estado
comprendido en una serie de atestados
policiales por terrorismo en la
situación ya era apremiante y ha venido
había tomado la decisión que estoy
segura que respaldado por un sector muy
importante de su propia bancada y del
partido pero libre que los llevó al
poder de iniciar una suerte de campaña
política
tanto para hacerse conocer él mismo como
persona
como para intentar recolectar firmas
para buscar una asamblea constituyente
que derogue la asamblea con la perdón y
la constitución actual y se imponga una
nueva constitución entonces
naturalmente esta segunda vuelta en la
que llevó al presidente al poder no fue
esté ganada por castillo no la ganó
castillo de manera abrumadora fue este
muy a las justas entonces la mitad del
país cuestiona estas tipo de actitudes y
en la otra mitad hubo también ya
personas que empezaron a sentirse
engañadas sobre todo por la presencia de
sendero luminoso en el gobierno josette
yo también hay en la ciudad de lima su
opinión era algo esperado se comentaba y
si fue así ya como no lo estaba
explicando cecilia acertada esta
decisión le parece a usted
muy bien muy buenas tardes ante todo
santiago cecilia también un saludo y
también a nuestro colega que está ya de
manera presencial profesor de la
universidad javeriana
es un gusto de verdad el poder tratar
esta temática el título que se ha
colocado de crisis sin fin bueno va muy
acorde con la situación política
lamentablemente desde la segunda vuelta
cuando el castigo es ungido como
presidente porque gana la elección hemos
tenido pues una serie de situaciones de
inestabilidad que no han ayudado digamos
a que encontremos una sobra luego de
cinco años bastante convulsionado de
gobierno pero sí hay que ser claros en
'la el gobierno a mi entender con este
cambio que sí se veía de equipo que era
insostenible el hecho mantener a guido
bellido como premier por los errores que
venía cometiendo por el uso en buena
cuenta también de la maquinaria estatal
para
proyectos meramente partidarios lo cual
obviamente decir cualquier idea de parte
institucionalizado por parte del partido
pero un libre partido gobierno que en
realidad es un partido que carece
institucionalidad y que está gobernado
por una élite que está enquistada y que
bueno en la lidera el señor la camisa
roja hay que ser bien claros en que esto
sí ha constituido un golpe timo y es
algo interesante que va de la mano ya
que tiene una lectura completa
la designación de el señor velarde o la
ratificación del señor velarde como el
presidente del banco central de reserva
que acá en el perú es un organismo
constitucionalmente autónomo que se
encarga de regular la política monetaria
a que voy a que si se pueden ver visos
de moderación y sobre todo de coherencia
con algo que ha venido preocupando mucho
a los agentes económicos en el país y
que yo sé paso aún estamos en una crisis
bastante complicada
es el hecho del mensaje respeto respeto
de la propia privada
o sea que en el estudio de france 24
quiero preguntarle estos cambios
radicales grandes estos remezones en los
gobiernos generan ciertas
entre entre el pueblo no genera buenos
sentimientos y menos cuando uno ve que
el presidente apenas lleva dos meses de
haber llegado al poder muy arriesgado
haber juzgado esta carta de haber hecho
un remezón ministerial solamente dos
meses haber comenzado el gobierno bueno
un saludo a usted a toda la audiencia a
los colegas que nos acompañan yo creo
que siempre se ha dicho que hay unos 100
días de luna de miel desde para
gobernantes elegidos democráticamente
gente que ha llegado a veces de repente
o hasta para papás entonces ese sentido
sí de sal es alarmante estamos en apenas
un par de meses y llegamos a este tipo
de situación no obstante nunca va a ser
llamémoslo
demasiado temprano si es necesario para
intentar corregir pero ya es una mala
señal que estamos viendo el posible
llamémoslo naufragio se podría decir de
la gobernabilidad del del presidente del
perú estamos tal vez es como viendo
una nueva llamémoslo alerta temprana de
lo que es la poca capacidad de generar
gobierno de rendir cuentas y una
política balcanizada en ese gran país y
también sufrido que es el perú y de no
poder terminar sus períodos
presidenciales entonces esto sigue en
fila y cuando observamos de afuera a
veces pensamos en la valentía que tienen
los peruanos de haber llegado a juzgar a
también a sus a sus mandatarios pero
también del espectáculo que se convierte
esto y la posible exageración en este
caso el presidente está previendo de
antemano un presidente castillo
vio las alarmas ya tal vez e entrado a
mediar en un debate que es muy
tradicional de las izquierdas que
siempre una izquierda de una a la
radical que es también la que lo apoya
para llegar al poder pero también por
con unos apoyos
no muy fuertes en el parlamento donde no
tiene claramente mayoría entonces ahí el
sistema de perú está está jugando con
fuego hace tiempo una rama ejecutiva que
no puede gobernar un sistema
parlamentario que trata de de caminar
hacia el modelo semi presidencial tal
vez que encontramos en algunos países
del mundo como poco es francia en que es
un camino complicado y tampoco puede
llegar a tener el presidente típico
fuerte hiper presidencial de otros
momentos del estero latinoamericana está
en una encrucijada del perú y ojalá
podamos ver lo que pueda gobernar porque
lo que queremos es que un presidente
tenga su mandatario completo gobierno y
pueda llegar a una rendición de cuentas
pero esto cobrándole un gran agotamiento
a la ciudadanía con todos estos cambios
geopolíticos y una inestabilidad que no
genera ningún tipo de
seguridad en ninguna de las áreas ni
económica ni política ni social cecilia
allí en el lima lo veíamos hoy en los
medios de comunicación en los análisis
que hacían varias personas allí la
palabra que más resalta es
gobernabilidad esa es la gran meta la
que quiere llegar pero para lograr tener
estabilidad política esto puede ser un
primer paso para lograr esa
gobernabilidad lo dice jose aquí en el
estudio el presidente castillo empezó a
oír las alarmas y dijo esto no va por
buen camino yo tomo medidas preventivas
antes de que empiecen a pasar unos
escenarios que los peruanos conocen muy
bien en pitch men
acusaciones y la gente en las calles
manifestándose
pero yo creyera que el presidente
castillo ha tomado exactamente medidas
correctivas porque ha visto hay un
análisis de la crisis él se ha visto
obligado
a mover algunas fichas y ha movido
algunas fichas pero el gobierno sigue
siendo un gobierno de izquierda radical
que será en esta ocasión en esta segunda
temporada vamos a estar llamarle así
pues más organizado por que los
personajes son personajes que se conocen
en el perú como la izquierda
limeña no pero no es una izquierda del
centro no es una izquierda progresista
este con grandes proyectos este más bien
es una izquierda que tiene una nada en
un enfrentamiento permanente y un
cuestionamiento más que un
enfrentamiento
con la izquierda regional que es a la
que le ha quitado la alfombra porque era
la izquierda de las regiones la que
había la que se había empoderado al
ganar las elecciones aunque por muy
poquito pero ganarlas y acceder al poder
estas personas estos dirigentes entonces
de líderes han sido desplazados por los
izquierdistas también radicales pero que
viven en lima
pero sufre un centralismo
dramático y estas personas si éste se
han impuesto entonces la la situación va
a la puntuación de crisis para continuar
probablemente hay un respiro de unos
cuantos días este y también claro un
sector de la prensa que ve con mejores
ojos personas más organizadas y sobre
todo menos agresivas pero en los hechos
son tal cual en los dirigentes de la
izquierda de las regiones de las
provincias están muy fastidiados y ellos
podrían convertirse en un en un grupo de
oposición muy radical a este gabinete y
claramente a este gobierno por su parte
el presidente castillo no ha roto
relaciones con el modal es que es el
nuevo rostro el rostro político de
sendero luminoso ha cambiado digamos ha
dejado y ha sacado del ministerio de
trabajo a un aliado suyo en que está en
esta agrupación el move df
sendero luminoso al fin de cuentas y a
pues lo ha puesto en el ministerio de
educación y eso también va a tener otro
le hable otro flanco porque la amplia
mayoría de los maestros porque es el el
ministro educación de un sindicato en el
que es enorme muy poderoso que se llama
sutep que son los maestros que están
este
en contra de este nuevo grupo de
maestros vinculados a sendero luminoso
esos maestros van a poner las cosas
también fuertes frente al gobierno
entonces yo lo que él solo es más crisis
más crisis jose está usted de acuerdo
con esa impresión habrá más crisis la
impresión que uno tiene acá afuera de
las fronteras peruanas y simplemente
pues conociendo lo que uno ve a través
de los medios internacionales y las
agencias y lo que investigamos con
nuestros periodistas allí en perú es que
da la sensación de que hay
desorganización en el gobierno lo decía
yo en la en la introducción del programa
el presidente tal parece que no logra
anclar fichas claves que le sirva para
apalancarse para comenzar a gobernar y
tomar altura y se nota mucho desorden
hacia el interior del gobierno como lo
vio usted
totalmente acuerdo o hay desorden
definitivamente este partido no es un
partido institucional izado al partido
que ha ganado el gobierno pero libre es
un partido que yo con la suma de
facciones radicales de facciones
moderadas pero todas facciones de
izquierdas que lo han apoyado además
también del votante y fujimorista
entonces ha llegado al poder recordemos
que esto ya se ha producido antes en el
perú lo que le pasó al pedro pablo
kuczynski fue algo muy parecido llegó
con el apoyo del antifujimorismo pero no
se quedó solo entonces lo que yo sí
estoy viendo acá es y ahí sí coincidió
con cecilia ese momento de que puede
haber algunos problemas con ciertas
alianzas locales con grupos radicales
pero también hay que tener en cuenta
algo castillo con esto se está acercando
a una tierra más progresista más
moderada y esta izquierda puede serle
también el soporte que él necesita y que
le permitirían crear con sectores medios
obviamente no va a ir con con la derecha
radical peruana
en algunas figuras emblemáticas
especialmente militantes y congresistas
del partido renovación nacional pero si
por ejemplo podría tener fuerzas o las
fuentes con fuerzas políticas medianas
digamos de un cierto centro que puedan
ayudarlo a gobernar
obviamente manteniendo una mejor
relación con el parlamento de hecho este
paso ya se ha anunciado que la banca de
perú libre del partido gobierno no va a
estar o sea del todo apoyándolo está
claro que ellos van a ir incluso contra
el gabinete de unir trabajes entonces
habría que ver en este caso también el
presidente en un cálculo de armar quizás
una bancada propia hay un partido
político que está impulsando que ese
partido magisterial y si pues
efectivamente creo que también ha
respetado una cierta cuota del partido
perú libre en la cartera el interior
pero ese es un tema como para irlo
desarrollando por kitsch en lo que sí
tenemos que advertir es esta es una
situación que si es que él tiene la
destreza o por lo menos los años
adecuados podría superar pero de no ser
así podemos caer nuevamente en una
crisis gobernabilidad más seria
o sea que en el estudio la gran pregunta
es si castillo es un político tan osado
tan
experimentado en las esferas políticas
como para mantener un gobierno con este
tipo de negociaciones que explica jose
con este escenario que explica cecilia
si puede llegar a sortear un gobierno
así estando con las bancadas del medio
con su bancada en contra pues parece que
le va a tocar inventarse una cara de
póker que por ahora no tiene y tal vez
el presidente con todo el respeto que
nos merece mandatario que han elegido
los peruanos y las peruanas pues también
hace parte de una nueva ola que la
venimos sintiendo en américa latina
desde desde hace unos 30 años y estaba
la llegada de los actores nuevos a la
política le llamaron anti políticos
ahora le podemos llamar también la nueva
política y hay gente pues increíble que
está enmarcada de la corrupción y el
hecho político pero también estamos
viendo entonces la inexperiencia la poca
preparación echamos de menos los
estadistas la gente también de la que
venía de los partidos que los partidos
se han desplomado y han perdido
popularidad para llegar justamente a un
personaje que tiene que bandearse como
yo creo que como el escenario como lo
están planteando mis colegas acá en el
foro está muy bien esas tensiones entre
entre lo regional entre el centralismo
peruano y que si justamente perú libre
que es el partido radical de izquierda
que lo ha impulsado le da la espalda
pues es que va a tener que poner cara de
póker y tratar de establecer alianzas
con lo que pueda para sostener un
gobierno y hablamos de alianzas que
pueden llegar a ser frágiles no son
llamémoslo coaliciones como las
entendemos los sistemas parlamentarios
europeos que son otro tipo de cuestiones
pero son las reglas que puede llegar a
funcionar de una por un lado yo diría
que hay que perderle el miedo también a
las a los acuerdos justamente eso se
trata la política y para eso están los
escenarios legislativos para establecer
consensos pero no hacer fácil de todos
modos pero tiene que intentarlo claro
pero sin sin sin experiencia política
gobernando teniendo que jugar todas
estas cartas y negociando cada tanto
pues ahí viene una frase que tal vez le
resultó este conocida que es un año de
aprendizaje y se va el año de
aprendizaje con gobiernos de cuatro años
y finalmente se pasa el tiempo y es poco
lo que progresan hago ahora la ronda a
la inversa entonces sigo con jose en la
ciudad de lima
y tranquila ya le voy a dar la palabra
quiero que hablemos de esta figura
controvertida que es guido bellido que
era tal vez el representante del ala de
la extrema izquierda peruana pasa ahora
a estar otra vez en el congreso en el
congreso de pero qué papel puede jugar
allí bellido después de este espaldarazo
que les dio el presidente y dejó a su
partido un poco mirando para el techo
bueno diría que en el congreso del
tendría que tener bastante
atención a los temas personales que va a
tener que enfrentar porque es de
conocimiento público acá en el país
las expresiones que él ha tenido contra
el parlamento
cuando fui justamente
premier el llevo la situación a un nivel
de falta entendimiento entre ejecutivo y
legislativo se fue el provocador contra
el eje en contra legislativo fuera de
eso él y otros
representantes como el señor bermejo por
ejemplo que también es un radical
estuvieron hablando de hasta ellos como
siempre parlamento y más allá el señor
tiene que solucionar canning de ese
encuentro
lamentable hasta que él tuvo contra una
parlamentaria que justamente la tercera
vicepresidenta la señora paty chirinos
entonces creo que él tiene que
solucionar ciertos temas que incluso ya
van hacia la escena en el ministerio
público porque ha habido
y recientemente un pronunciamiento de
las autoridades jurisdiccionales también
sobre este último caso que acabo de
mencionar él podría incluso en una
situación complicada yo creo que el
liderazgo le remitía contra el gobierno
más que por el señor brillo que va a
tener un frente interno la visión a más
en balde marcharon que la caja de
resonancia de su hermano vladimir que
también enfrenta problemas en la externa
porque tiene un proceso con la
organización criminal lo dinámico del
centro la situación de gobernabilidad si
uno lo ve en el partido pero libre es
una situación complicada y efectivamente
o sea lo único preparado para el
gobierno esto le cayó por gravedad ante
una situación electoral tse donde
definitivamente pues ganó la elección
pero
quiero
enfatizar en que la situación en el
congreso si es que castillo
no gracias a las articulaciones debidas
con sectores de izquierda moderada y con
sectores digamos del espectro político
que pudiesen ser dialogante podría
verdaderamente mejorar bastante y
tenemos que ver o sea hay una claridad
en que él no es el estadista que quizás
necesita el perú definitivamente en la
política en general últimamente los
estadistas están un poco ausentes pero
sí hay que tener en cuenta que la
destreza que él quizás tuvo con su
experiencia como sindicalista no lo
tiene que llevar una experiencia ción y
tiene definitivamente y apostar por el
diálogo para lograr conciencia hacer
política importante es ese aspecto que
usted señala o se halla en la ciudad de
lima pasó darle la palabra a cecilia
sobre los respaldos políticos que puedan
recibir este nuevo gabinete entonces al
interior del parlamento peruano que es
lo más inmediato es lo que sigue en este
capítulo de renovación de 30 días para
que sea aprobado para ver si esto se
pone en marcha ya hablamos un poco de
esos apoyos como los de usted
y
dijimos al inicio que no tendrá a la
bancada completa el sol partido que lo
llevó al poder eso definitivamente ya
está ya está dicho y que así va a ser
lamentablemente para el presidente pero
quién tienen más posibilidad de maniobra
de mi opinión ahora no es el presidente
sino es más bien la oposición porque
habiendo perdido el presidente a la gran
mayoría de sus
congresistas en el parlamento pues
necesitará de que la oposición le apoye
y para eso él tiene que aprender a hacer
política cosa que sabe pero desde el
punto de vista sindical él es un líder
sindical él no es un político de
trayectoria y por otro lado no es una
persona
muy preparada y tampoco tienen muchas
capacidades no las ha mostrado en todo
caso hasta el momento por ejemplo no ha
declarado a la prensa
en todos estos días que son casi 70
tiene una actitud muy agresiva contra el
periodismo este cada vez que puede en
una plaza pública agrede el concepto
básico de la libertad de expresión
entonces le falta
mucho para hilar fino
pienso que si la oposición logra
organizarse porque tampoco es que
tengamos una oposición muy bien
organizada en este momento pero si es
que esta oposición logrará organizarse
podría ser más bien quien pudiera usar
la oportunidad para la negociación si me
parece importante que es mi país pueda
entrar en un espacio de conversación de
diálogo de negociación en efecto a su
vida y que ser así lo ha decidido el
país los electores y los ciudadanos
votaron así mitad mitad entonces
es algo que tiene que empezar a ocurrir
este definitivamente es los sectores
radicales que no son que no son
cualquier cosa porque son las personas
que han llevado al presente castigo al
poder le van a pasar la factura y allí
va a estar su mayor mínimo ya vamos a
hablar cecilia de esa polarización hay
en perú pasó a preguntarle aquí en el
estudio a jose sobre el costo político
que tiene esto para perú a nivel
internacional en la región estamos en
una crisis sanitaria en la pandemia los
países están tratando de de salir
adelante pero estamos haciendo frente
internacionalmente a muchas crisis
migratoria el kobe 19 y ahora se suma a
esto para perú que tampoco ha tenido
fácil claro estamos viendo unas
llamémoslo
señalamientos sobre la región porque nos
estamos viendo qué pasa con bolivia
justamente un país también vecino
estamos viendo también un cambio de
rumbo en el ecuador y esa manera
entonces las apuestas de una agenda
izquierda que planteó el presidente
castillo que ahora vemos entra en crisis
pues tampoco tienen el florecimiento de
la izquierda de hacer una década cuando
había respaldos y también en venezuela
estaba el presidente chávez etcétera
entonces en este momento no están las
cosas para para ahondar en esta agenda
posiblemente y con esta separación puede
que haya otros arreglos que ya no se han
anunciado aquí en el programa pero para
la región obviamente esto plantea una
serie de problemas y el principal es
cuánto más va a resistir la economía
peruana que de todos modos en los
últimos 30 años creció tiene un pib que
llegó a crecer que tal vez tiene muchos
problemas para redistribuir pero es un
país que a veces no puede decir que la
economía funciona a pesar de la política
no sé si uno con todo el cariño por ese
gran país que es que es el perú y cómo
va a sostener el embate estamos
esperando es cuanto más aguanta la
economía pero la que de todos modos
sigue siendo importante y como
justamente entonces el país rehén causa
temas de seguridad que son importantes
que todavía están presentes el tema de
la pandemia el tema de atender las
regiones el tema de la descentralización
tan pendiente de esperar deuda pendiente
histórica y que fuera de eso no pase un
poco que pasó en américa central que se
estabiliza un país se estabiliza
nosotros fácilmente acá no es tan fácil
pero también tenemos que tener mucho
cuidado entonces en el área andina que
es muy importante entonces peronistas
ariel adelante y yo creo que la economía
va a tener que funcionar a pesar de la
política claro pasó a preguntarle así si
le hacemos la ronda a la inversa estamos
hablando de la polarización rápidamente
también porque llevamos llegando al
final del programa cecilia se profundiza
la polarización en perú con este tipo de
hechos con estas remezones políticos
yo diría que más que una polarización
que es lo que hemos venido viviendo
durante los últimos meses la campaña
electoral y los primeros meses de
gobierno donde el presidente castillo lo
que empieza a definirse mejor es un
fraccionamiento no porque éste no
olvidemos que tanto castillo como ha
venido el saliente primer ministro
estuvieron
acusando a la población precisamente al
enfrentamiento al encono entre región
capital costa sierra rico pobre blanco
solo realmente algo lamentable en hojas
lo que ellos en su concepto se llama la
lucha de clases no es cierto le pusieron
en acción demanda vehemente este pero
eso ha fracasado ha fracasado
el exponente emblemático de esta
confrontación que él había vivido ha
tenido que salir por la ventana y eso a
los peruanos no les agrada a los dos no
les gustan
los que pierden les gustan los que ganan
entonces
yo creo que allí es ese tema de la
polarización de la confrontación uno
contra otro pues ese tema se va a quedar
en un espacio un espacio que
desgraciadamente tiene mucho que ver con
los en la parte de la sierra sur del
perú pero en la costa hay otro tipo de
necesidades y en la capital hay otro
tipo de necesidades entonces vamos a ver
más bien un país más fraccionado que
polariza
y jose en la ciudad de lima a sus
impresiones comentarios sobre lo que han
dicho nuestros dos invitados aquí en el
estoy también hay en la ciudad de lima
coincido con lo que dice cecilia en el
punto de la fragmentación pero también
hay que tener en cuenta algo hay que ver
un poco el mapa electoral y mirando las
elecciones que vienen en el próximo año
que son las elecciones regionales y
municipales en 2022 se van a elegir casi
autoridades 100 algo de aproximadamente
1900 jurisdicciones electorales entonces
hablar sobre el tema de la polarización
ideológica entre listones creo que eso
debería hacerse en base a la evidencia
normalmente los movimientos regionales
sobre todo en la zona sur y la zona sur
en realidad es una zona bastante radical
en el país pero es diferente al gran
norte es muy poblado tiene mucha más
población electoral y es una zona más
pro mercado que tiene otra visión otro
enfoque igual que la zona costera y la
ciudad de lima que prácticamente pues
tiene un tercio del electorado entonces
debemos tener nosotros en consideración
y más allá de ver el mapa de los apoyos
que pudiesen tener posiciones radicales
debemos ver como este congreso el
congreso para mí si vamos a un infinito
muy tradicional y desfasada de izquierda
derecha y centro hoy en día podríamos
decir tomando en cuenta esto manera
referencial sobre todo palentina
nuestros televidentes que estamos pues
y la presencia de una izquierda y
derecha radical algo que no habíamos o
se ha advertido desde hace mucho tiempo
podríamos nosotros incluso pensar que
esto no lo vemos de los años 80 o quizás
antes del golpe será el relajo los años
30 entonces habría que tener en
consideración que ahora el espacio de
centro y así lo define incluso el perfil
del elector peruano es un espacio donde
la gente lo que busca es un consenso y
agra y ver si es que castillo está en
capacidad al consensos o llegamos al
final del programa paso entonces a las
conclusiones cecilia que cree usted que
va a pasar en los próximos meses en las
próximas semanas muy puntual por favor
para que todos alcancen a su conclusión
adelante
lamentablemente en mi país pues nada
está listo lo que vaya a sobrevenir va a
tener que ver de la habilidad de las
cabezas de los poderes pero con la
colisión de este choque de trenes
lamentablemente es algo que yo veo
inevitable por las situaciones por los
en los radicales en los radicales de los
líderes que sobre todo éste habitan en
el ejecutivo entonces pues no sabemos no
ponemos este donosti carnada pero yo
creo que la crisis
entonces
la crisis aquí en el estudio rápidamente
su conclusión por ahora se detiene ese
impulso radical que inclusive nos habla
de una constituyente para hablar de una
economía popular de mercado entonces
ahora creo que el golpe va a ser duro la
certidumbre va a continuar y la derecha
va a tener que también aprender a
negociar fuerte con este gobierno hasta
donde punto hasta qué punto puede
frenarlo pero me gusta también lo que
dice nuestro invitado josé el centro
está vacío ahí puede estar el consenso
si no está es ese no se ocupa ese lugar
que puede ser el salvavidas de este
gobierno y también para el bien de los
peruanos entonces la incertidumbre se
puede convertir en una crisis mayor y
pronto no terminará este gobierno hace
20 segundos para su conclusión
rápidamente por favor
complementando lo que dijo cecilia pero
quizás con otro enfoque yo considero que
radicalismo también existe en el
congreso tenemos en la visión
tradicional de derecha radical ratificó
que la búsqueda del centro es importante
para lograr consenso y gobernabilidad
pues muchas gracias a cecilia a jose en
la ciudad de lima ya jose aquí en el
estudio de france 24 por haber
compartido con nosotros sus impresiones
sobre este tema la crisis en perú
ustedes pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con nuestra programación
buenas noches
[Música]